sin duda alguna Raúl una de las mejores
demostraciones ofensivas en lo que
llevamos esta copa mundo de Qatar 2022
Brasil que volvió a hacer esa selección
que atacaba sin parar que regateaba eso
con el regreso de Neymar su estrella
después de dos partidos de ausencia
Neymar autor del segundo tanto para la
cannareña en Este triunfo por cuatro a
uno contra el combinado asiático una
imagen reconoció posterior a este
partido que después de esa lesión que
sufrió en el encuentro inaugural contra
servía que estuvo llorando porque tenía
miedo de lo que le pudiera ocurrir
finalmente demostró que está en óptimas
condiciones jugó 80 minutos mientras que
algunos compañeros de Neymar como
rafinha ya se atreven incluso a hablar
de una eventual dijo rafinha que le
gustaría jugar una final contra Portugal
pero también mantiene la cautela porque
antes en cuartos de final está Croacia
una Croacia que de nuevo con mucho
oficio eliminó esta vez en octavos de
final a Japón en penaltis con Dominique
libakovic su portero como gran estrella
quien detuvo de lanzamientos de los
penaltis Cross Así que sigue con su
idilo en las fases eliminatorias de la
Copa mundo no gana un partido en 90
minutos en una Estancia eliminatoria
desde que lo hicieron contra Rumanía en
la copa mundo de 1998 con un gol de
dabor zucker Juan ahora hablemos de lo
que ocurrirá el día de hoy dos partidos
de octavos y uno donde además de deporte
se puede ver la geopolítica en todo esto
que vamos a ver en la cancha hablemos
entonces del primer partido de la
jornada entre Marruecos y España
sí partido que transcurre aquí en el
estadio 974 desde que venimos para ese
estadio notamos ya que la afición
marroquí está muy presente Aquí hay
reportes de que ayer en las oficinas de
los etiquetes de los boletos había hasta
1000 aficionados marroquíes y que yo a
ver hasta altercados porque estaban
buscando una boleta de reportes incluso
de que la asociación de fútbol de
Marruecos que la embajada de Marruecos
Aquí está entregando boletos Royal
airrock la principal aerolínea de este
país está flotando cuatro vuelos
adicionales para aquí se espera entonces
una presencia importante de estos
aficionados aquí que se van a enfrentar
contra España en un duelo histórico con
España la duda de César spilicueta con
Marruecos la duda decide estar a
finalmente su lateral estrella Ash la
noche termina así con el partido entre
Portugal y Suiza Portugal que llega aquí
lastrado por esas declaraciones del
seleccionador Fernando Santos quien dijo
que no le gustó el gesto de Cristiano
Ronaldo que
mostró algo de queja cuando fue
reemplazado en la victoria en la derrota
contra del sur al cierre de la fase de
grupos mientras que por parte de Suiza
el combinado el bético que sueña con
volver a unos cuartos de final Como ya
lo hiciera en su copa mundo en 1954
antes Eso sí el partido que les cuento
entre Marruecos y España quienes estadio
el estadio más fríos sin duda alguna en
este mundial de doja Yo por eso me vine
preparado con esta chaqueta porque de
verdad que lo del aire acondicionado
aquí en el education City Perdón es
increíble